information classical information essentially emerges as a special case and I'll now explain how that
works specifically we'll see how probabilistic States can be represented by density
matrices let's start with classical States beginning with a simple
example here are the density Matrix representations of the zero and one standard basis states of a
cubit we associate these states with the classical States 0 and one and so we can think about these density matrices as
representing those States that's very simple and we can easily generalize the
example if we have a system whose classical State set is Sigma then classical State a is represented by or
is associated with the density Matrix k a bra a that Matrix has a single one in the
diagonal entry whose row and column corresponds to the classical State a and every other entry is
zero probabilistic states are represented by convex combinations of matrices of this form which is natural
given what we know about density matrices and how they work specifically that convex combinations of density matrices represent random or
probabilistic selections of quantum States for example let's suppose that we
have a system X whose classical State set includes the integers 0 through n minus one for some positive integer n of
course there's little or no generality lost in assuming that our classical State set has this form if we had a
different classical State set we could simply rename the classical States in this way and it's often pretty venient to make the assumption that our
classical State sets look like this in large part because that makes it easier to write things explicitly in terms of
vectors and matrices supposing that we have a probabilistic state of the system X
represented by a probability Vector in the usual way we can associate this probabilistic state with a density
Matrix as is shown on the screen we take the weighted average of the density matrices corresponding to
the different classical States and what what we get is a diagonal density Matrix in particular we see the probabilities
along the diagonal of this Matrix and every other entry is equal to zero of course this is a density Matrix
we expect that to be true but we can also reason it directly it's a herian matrix its Trace
is equal to one because the probability sum to one and in the case of a diagonal matrix the IG values are the diagonal
entries and they're all non- negative because they're probab abilities also notice that every
diagonal density Matrix meaning one whose off diagonal entries are all zero must look like this so in a nutshell
probabilistic States can be associated with diagonal density matrices notice by the way that this is consistent with the
informal interpretation of the entries of density matrices that I mentioned at the start of the lesson in particular nothing is in
Quantum superposition here it's basically just classical Randomness and correspondingly all of the off diagonal
entries are zero earlier in this series we discussed the spectral theorem and we did that
specifically for unitary matrices in the context of phase estimation the spectal theorem is more
General than that however meaning that it tells us something about a broader class of matrices than just unitary
matrices and in particular it applies to a class of matrices called normal matrices which include all matrices as
well as unary matrices what we'll do now is to take a look at a different statement of this theorem this time focusing on just
positive semi-definite majores and then we'll see that it tells us something very interesting and critically important about density
matrices suppose p is any positive semi-definite Matrix so that includes any density Matrix as well as any
positive semi-definite Matrix that doesn't happen to have Trace equal to one p is positive semi-definite so it has to
be square or in other words N by n for some choice of N and we're going to need to refer to that number n so let N be
chosen appropriately or another way to say all this is assume p is n byn what the theorem tells us in this case is that
there must exist an orthonormal basis of vectors which we'll name s0 through S nus one along with non- negative real
numbers Lambda 0 through Lambda nus one such that P can be expressed as is shown
here on the screen in words if we multiply each Lambda K to Kai k * brasai K and then
sum ofall K from 0 to n minus one then we'll get P this is called a spectral
decomposition of P each Lambda K is necessarily an igen value of p and each s is a unit igen Vector of P
corresponding to that igen value if you look back to lesson 7 on phase estimation you'll find a similar theorem
for unitary matrices there the igen values are complex numbers on the unit circle rather than being non- negative real
numbers but otherwise it's the same idea and these are really just two special cases of a more General theorem known as
the spectral theorem it doesn't work for every Matrix you need the Matrix to commute with its
own conjugate transpose and that's what it means for a matrix to be normal but we do in fact always have
that for both unitary matrices and positive semi-definite matrices and for herian matrices more generally where
we'll always have relig values but not necessarily non- negative ones so that's a statement of the
spectral theorem for just positive semi-definite matrices and now let's see what it tells us about density
matrices what it tells us is that for an arbitrary n byn density Matrix we can always express that Matrix as a convex
combination of n pure States and moreover we can take those n pure states to be
orthogonal that follows quite directly from the theorem together with a basic fact from linear algebra which is that
the sum of the igen values of any Matrix is always equal to the trace of that Matrix in other words all we're really
doing here is renaming the igen values p 0 through PN minus one and then observing that when we do that and
collect those IG values into an nend dimensional Vector we necessarily get a ability Vector because they all have to be non- negative and their sum equals
the trace of row which is one because row is a density Matrix so that's pretty simple but it's
really quite fundamental conceptually what it tells us is that every density Matrix no
matter how complicated it might seem could arise from first selecting an orthonormal basis of whatever system
we're talking about and then randomly choosing a Quantum state from that basis According to some choice for the prob